are you okay with Hamas terrorists
continuing to
exist here's a journalist in the capital
trying to uh ask ilhan if Hamas is bad
did they do anything bad like she could
just turn and say yeah beheading
children is bad but no she can't do
it you P her a ceasefire are you okay
with Hamas terrorists continuing to
exist do you think that Israel should
just lay down their arms and not try to
get the hostages out of
Gaza how can Israel have a SE fire with
terrorists whose entire mission is to
wipe out their exist please you're
blocking the elevator she's got how can
they have a seire if they're trying to
wipe out this crazy lady don't worry
about ignore this crazy lady don't worry
about her those are all completely
legitimate questions and you have to
understand ilhan Omar does support Hamas
how hard would it be for her even if she
doesn't believe it like if she was smart
and doesn't believe let's say it is my
belief and I think it's fairly obid
obvious the evidence proves it that she
supports him us she would gladly I think
she would gladly gladly have those 8
million Jews killed you'd have to kill a
whole bunch of Israeli Arabs she would
be fine with another genocide I think
she deeply hates America she came here
ascertained incredible power she's
destroyed Minnesota okay fine but how
hard would it be if she was just like
trying to be a little bit better not not
even trying to be a little bit better if
she was trying to be a little more
clever for her own side shouldn't she
just turn to the person and say well of
course you know Hamas beheading children
is bad but I but I stand up for the
people of Gaza like that wouldn't be
that hard to say but she won't even give
an inch on that and nobody in the
Democrat Party nobody has the balls to
say anything about
it